one specific goal in Jack Reacher was
just to make it how Tom Cruise would
feel it he's such a physical actor who
does his own stunts you want to have the
sound support that vulnerability and
it's important for him to sort of
recreate that experience for the
audience he wants the audience to feel
what he's feeling Jack Reacher Purple
Heart Silver Star you're a legend
what I secured the most important thing
about being a film composer is
understanding a story breaking it down
and we got to come up with ideas that
knows the story so Jack Reacher's
obviously can have action and espionage
and you know all the sorts of things you
associate with it in this particular
movie as well as that there's a dramatic
element so you still get the action hero
but because of the other story in the
film with Samantha it opens up this
musical Avenue so that you can have a
bit of counterpoint in the score it was
under my command we don't have time for
this one fact you have a full range
surround is really really important
having the correct or the most elevated
reproduction system whether it's visual
or audio just means that all of these
things deliver like crazy where's Jack
Reacher's gonna have a shootout this was
really important for us to help create
the geography by having the gunfire and
different speakers to say okay they're
off to the left there behind us what
have you
and of course how the sound effects
experience really kind of brings you
into that world there's a viscera in the
in the action and the movement and I
feel like the scale of that is in its
correct context you know with it with a
huge screen there is that fear oh you
and your voice join with you here is
excitement the relation to the
filmmakers have with IMAX I feel is very
important because it assures that it is
representative the way that they want
the IMAX experience
is not only a great visual and sound
experience
but that's perpetuated by the fact that
the rooms get tuned every day it just
creates a better overall experience
this is IMAX of course it's gonna be
played the way the filmmakers intended
it to play
you